thank you
well thank you very very much David and
uh good afternoon everybody great to be
here at this and this uh brand Finance
Global brand Summit Global Soft power
Summit and um thank you that I'm
delighted to be to be sticking up for
the other point of view I have to give
at hopstat uh last year and I'm going to
give you a bit of an analysis of soft
power folks and I'm I'm Gonna Be by
saying I was going for a run uh the
other day in in the park and the trouble
with the the these days it gets lighter
and lighter so that I become more easy
to recognize under my beanie hat and
some fit young Geezer shot past me
looking actually a bit uh not much here
a little bit like one of my former
advisors and he sang out a cheery London
greeting
one guy he said and
I I am I'm normally impervious to these
these types of things but I'm afraid
this time I I seized and I thought you
you rotter I thought it's a beautiful
day it's a beautiful Park and the Sun is
just peeping over the gorgeous London
Skyline for much of which I gave
planning permission the swans and the
Coots are all innocently doing their
thing and you have to go and be so rude
and do we have to put up another sign by
the one that says don't feed the duck
saying don't be don't Shout at the
politicians and then I I relaxed and
I I thought
I thought
what a wonderful country it is that we
live in and how privileged I am
to be shouted at on my morning run
because it shows how minimal is the
distance between the government and the
government
and if you doubt what I'm saying then
just try to imagine Vladimir Putin
with or without his T-shirt running
around red square and being shouted at
and what will they do with it would they
they would they do that would they shut
would they shouted they shattered I mean
they wouldn't they would scatter from
his path like pigeons and what we had
there and that admittedly somewhat
one-sided exchange was therefore
something of incalculable value to this
country and to our economy which is the
freedom
to say more or less what you like to
more or less whomsoever you choose and
as I say this I'm I'm conscious of
people in Britain today are worried
about a sense that they are being
muzzled and of course people should be
vigilant about freedom of speech when
we're boudlerizing Roald Dahl but
nothing and no one is going to stop me
reciting the song of the Oompa Loompas
about Augustus Loop which you will
remember
Augustus Gloop Augustus Gloop the great
big greedy Lincoln poop
what's wrong with that made me weak with
laughter as a child and frankly I'd be
very surprised if anybody at sis in
Vauxhall behaved towards their
secretaries as Bond behaved towards a
money Penny but that doesn't mean we
should be banned from Reading Fleming's
novels and in all this debate we should
never confuse our feelings of irritation
at wokeness or political correctness
with the genuine Terror inspired by
authoritarian systems where journalists
are shot for insulting politicians where
they are not hailed for exposing
corruption but jailed and we should
remember how lucky we are to live in a
country and a culture where speech and
thought are so free because it's those
freedoms freedom of speech freedom to
live your life how you choose provided
You Do no harm to others
freedom to love whomsoever you choose
that turn this city have turned the city
in this country into a great magnet for
talent the world's top chefs
at one stage I think in London I used to
say when I was married we had more
Michelin stars than Paris so the French
were so alarmed by this as they turned
out let the media stand in a kind of
North Korean way uh to overtook us we
have the world's best Minds in this
country that's why we have four of the
top 10 universities in the world one
Cambridge College boasting more Nobel
prizes I think than Russia and China
combined the world's most astonishingly
gifted artists and and musicians and
actors I think at one stage six of the
best selling songs in the world were
written in this country we have the
world's best cultural scene the world's
best museums here in London the British
museum
has more visitors per year
than about seven whole EU countries
and
um thing for my diplomacies you can see
and it is that fantastic concentration
of riches in one building that holds up
a mirror to all of humanity and tells
the story of the evolution of the human
spirit and so if you give back the Elgin
marbles to Greece
then you leave a huge gap in that
narrative
and above all you have no answer in the
years ahead to the theoretical claims
for restitution from Egypt and Iraq
Syria Lebanon turkey Nigeria
everywhere whose Treasures are housed in
Bloomsbury and suddenly in trying to
please the world and correct thinking
you've deprived the world of one of its
great treasures and cut some vital
panels from its great pageant of human
progress
those gods and hearers came to our
country in 1812
as refugees from the ottoman Lime Kiln
they were going to be melted down to
make cement
and they'd become part of our Lives we
can't send them away any more than we
should Deport the 40 percent of
londoners who were born abroad including
me by the way people who come here
because they sense that excitement and
that freedom and they know that they
will not be judged here and they won't
feel the Lash of prejudice
they know that they will be coming to a
safe Society where the police will apply
the law to everyone high or low I used
to make a
a joke about how they once arrested
prince Andrew in the Shrubbery of
Buckingham Palace which I thought was
pretty funny until they actually find me
having lunch at my place at the cabinet
table in 10 Downing Street although I
still don't understand the uh the
rationale behind it I do understand the
key point that the law is enforced here
without fear or favor and that is the
greatest freedom of all Freedom under
the law because they don't have that
everywhere and it is freedom under the
law that enables the political and
economic freedom on which we rely I mean
capitalism the freedom to spend our own
money I mean democracy
freedom to vote for whomsoever we choose
and of course freedom to kick that
person out of the next election
even our capitalism without democracy
and there are some countries
that do well
on the soft power index that come into
that category
and you can even have democracy without
capitalism
at least I think you can try I think
Democratic socialism is the program for
Kia storm was labor party although I'm
not sure I don't I don't want to I want
to I don't want to offend the the human
Bollard and wind him up even more than I
have done uh already great so crash a
Rooney's news Fest is like one uh by the
way I just want to just just point out
uh purely for for accuracies I when I
stepped down we were only a handful of
points uh behind uh the labor party at
that moment back in time I'm just I'm
just I'm just saying that
but if if you want real success if you
want to be a soft power superpower like
the UK then you need both you need
capitalism and democracy
democracy matters because if Putin had
been living in a free Society with a
free media he would never have made the
catastrophic mistake of invading Ukraine
he would never have been so deluded
about the true nature of that country
imagine if we had the BBC wonderful
organizations sponsoring us today uh he
on his case let alone Tory back benches
instead of listening to a cabal of
cronies he would have known that the
ukrainians are a great and patriotic
people and that they would fight for
every inch of their land
and if you want a perfect example of why
democracy and capitalism need to go
together look at the covid vaccines who
in this room has been vaccinated
just about everybody absolutely
everybody anybody not been vaccinated
has any oh there you go okay A Brave
self or whatever reason not to be
vaccinated fine but can I ask you as a
matter of Interest Who Who had who had
Sputnik
anybody you have Sputnik
who had no
who had cyanovac or cyano Farm
okay
a couple okay who had AstraZeneca
I did
who had AstraZeneca or Pfizer
like I think there you go AstraZeneca
made at uh invented in Oxford room
temperature vaccine licensed around the
world I think was one of the most
beautiful and moving examples of UK soft
power I can think of in in recent years
and uh it's a it's a notable fact
that after all the years in which we
were told you could have
capitalism without democracy
it was the free western open societies
tend to be the winners in the soft power
index
that produced the vaccines that actually
work and by the way I think everyone
should feel free to point this out
I was I made this point at this point in
Singapore not long ago and it was felt
to be so controversial the organizers
actually had to apologize to and the
guardian said I hope the Guardians here
the guardian said my speech was shocking
I just want to check everybody's all
right with me saying that
I mean and then the guardian the
guardian is bearing up at the heart of
this idea of Economic and political
freedom is the idea of autonomy
the idea of trusting people and families
to make their own decisions I own their
own homes spend their own money because
that autonomy is not only morally right
it's the way to allow us all to be as
creative and productive as possible and
to enjoy and make the best use of the
talents we have
and that sense of autonomy
for individuals and for for families has
always turned out to be the most
Innovative and efficient way of running
an economy
and what goes for
people and for families is also in my
view true of countries
and you know I here I come to the point
that Giver hofstadt might not agree with
because that in my view and I'm
conscious that this is not necessarily
now a universal consensus not the devil
was uh in my view that was what brexit
was all about
on June the 23 2016 people made a
momentous choice
they wanted to be free they took back
control of their money their borders and
their laws and they did it against the
opposition
of the vast majority of the ruling
classes in this country
and in all the great power centers
of our country
what used to be called The Establishment
the the Bishops the BBC
you know if I'm not you know
being too controversial yeah the CBI
most readers of the times I'm told
uh were in fact 70 or 80 percent of the
readers of the times were in favor of
remain most MPS
vast majority of members of the of the
House of Lords massively Pro remain
remember I don't know what the balance
would be in in this distinguished
audience but as soon as that happened
there was a concerted attempt to reverse
it or at least to stop the UK leaving
properly and the treasury in particular
wanted the UK to remain in alignment
with the EU legal order that's why we
had all those arguments over the years
about the so-called Checkers deal and
many of us rejected
that approach
out of pure logic we said there was no
point in leaving the EU if you were
going to remain locked in the single
Market there was no point in being a
battle State there was no point in being
a rule taker
you might as well be in the EU
so for years before trench warfare
people like Steve Baker uh David Davis
many others were heroic and as a result
we are out of the Customs Union and
we're out of the single Market
but you remember the the circumstances
in which we had to do that deal under
the terms of the Ben Bert act or as it
was called the so-called surrender act
we couldn't leave unless we agreed to
the eu's terms and there was no doubt
that we faced a particular problem in
Ireland where we were told that we faced
a choice
if the if the UK wanted to come out of
the Customs Union and the EU internal
Market
and
to keep an open border across the island
of Ireland
which we emphatically did for the sake
of Peace on the island and the Belfast
Good Friday agreement
then we would have to make sure that we
somehow checked on Goods that might go
from Great Britain to Northern Ireland
and then on into Ireland and that is
what the protocol does and purely to
help the EU we agreed to check on those
goods uh entering Northern Ireland as I
say that might go on to Ireland and I
thought those checks would not be
onerous since there isn't actually that
much stuff that falls into that category
most of the goods stay in Northern
Ireland and this is all my fault I'm
fully exceptional honestly and the
protocol itself and this is why I signed
it contains lots of reassuring phrases
about how Northern Ireland remains in
the custom territory of the UK and will
benefit from participation in the United
Kingdom's independent trade policy the
protocol notes the importance of
maintaining the integral part place of
Northern Ireland in the United Kingdoms
internal Market
but beneath the paint and plaster there
was the Cold Steel reality
of EU control
and the commission was in charge and not
the UK
and contrary to my hopes there they did
not apply it sensibly and we had that
mad ban on sausages and potted plants
and tractors and heaven knows what
people are unable to send Parcels to
their grandchildren we had very serious
diversion of trade
as British retailers couldn't move Goods
like shortbread from one country of one
part of the country uh to the other
even if they didn't actually have stores
in in Ireland itself
and of course these everyday
frustrations were particularly acute for
unionist communities in Northern Ireland
who felt they were being cut off from
the rest of the UK
which I which I bitterly regretted and I
thought was absurd because the large
majority of Northern Ireland trade is
with the rest of the UK
and the problem I had
was there was nothing legally
that the UK government could do
because we've given that power away
and that is why we had the bill
to fix it
and to sort it out and we that's why I
believe we had that majority
of 80 seats because I think the people
in this country sensed that we needed to
fix it and that bill does fix and it's
still in the in Parliament it does fix
all these problems it removes any border
checks down the Irish sea it would allow
the the UK to determine vat rules in vat
rules in Northern Ireland uh state aid
subsidies and so on and above all
it would allow Northern Irish firms to
make goods and of any kind put them on
the market in Northern Ireland if they
conform to UK standards and not EU
standards so there's a dual standard
regime was envision envisaged
and I don't believe for one moment that
it would have necessitated Czechs north
south certainly not by the UK we would
not have done anything of the kind it
would have kept and respected the
balance of the The Good Friday agreement
now
the EU
did not like that bill
they did not like it
because it took away their control
and above all because it frustrated
their key objective
by keeping Northern Ireland in the
single market for goods and that made it
much more difficult for the UK to
diverge and to do things differently
because of the strains that would place
on the on the Union
and I can tell you that in all my
conversations with uh with our friends
uh in the EU over the over the years
it was that idea
of of Divergence that whole sort of
Singapore on Thames concept whatever you
may think of it it was that idea of
Divergence that they feared
the UK actually taking advantage
of brexit freedoms so as to be more
competitive
and so in my view they used the Northern
Ireland problem as a way of keeping us
more or less where they wanted
so that their system the European court
of justice and all the rest were still
glumped on and in some important respect
still in charge of part of the UK and I
remember Angela Merkel actually coming
up to me at a I think it was a G20
Summit and saying if you continue with
this bill
it will be
a Shakespearean tragedy
well she turned she don't know if you're
right there that I leave it to you to
work out which tragedy it was
and and so I was thrilled when in June
that bill sailed through the has Commons
unamended
I was pleased when the present prime
minister earned and his predecessor said
uh that they would continue with it
and
so when I look at the deal that we have
now I of course have have mixed feelings
I'm I'm conscious of the of where the of
where the political momentum is and and
people's deep desire just to to get on
and this has got to be about the people
of Northern Ireland the 1.9 million
people their businesses and their lives
and given that we have got rid
of the bill I can see why so many people
are attracted to accepting a compromise
and I agree passionately with Sir
Jeffrey Donaldson whom I have the
highest regard that the people of
Northern Ireland need their assembly and
they they need uh their government and
it's look it's not for me to advise Sir
Jeffrey uh but I hope that he can find a
way of reconciling himself and his party
to this outcome which is the the fact
that we have and getting back into into
Stormont
but
and I am conscious I'm not going to be
thanked for for saying this but it's I
think it's my job to to do so we must be
clear about what is really going on here
this is not about the UK taking back
control and although there are easements
this is really a version of the solution
that was being offered last year to Liz
truss when she was foreign secretary
this is the the EU graciously unbending
to allow us to do what we want in our
own country
not by our laws but by theirs
they're not scrapping hundreds of pages
of EU regulations they're passing EU law
they're passing new regulations to allow
British goods to pass from one part of
this country to another still under EU
law but with what they hope will be
lighter bureaucracy
21 data points on the forms instead of
80 to be completed by trusted traders
who can show the EU that they have
certain assets and goods for sale in
Northern Ireland and to be prominently
labeled not for EU among many other
provisions and restrictions look we've
got to Hope
we've got to Hope that it works
and genuinely reduces frictions I'm
particularly concerned that Goods going
for processing and Manufacturing in
Northern Ireland from from Great Britain
Goods that are part of a supply of the
supply chain seem to be going through
the red lane for firms above a certain
size which seems pretty pretty crazy not
supportive of the UK internal market and
what this will certainly not do is allow
goods made in Northern Ireland to be
made according to UK standards unless
they're also EU standards for sale in
Northern Ireland or at least it is very
very unclear the extent to which that
would be allowed it's it's very unclear
if the foodstuffs for Motor
Manufacturing and and all the rest of it
the the EU single Market remains
Paramount and
in that sense
this deal helps to accomplish the key
objective that I that I spoke of and so
it acts as a drag anchor
on Divergence
and which which as I say is the point of
brexit there's no point in brexit unless
you do things differently and then
beneath the bother and the hassle of
these rules
you have to ask yourself the key
question
who who votes for the people who decide
these rules
who votes for the people who decide how
your pet dog or cat can get to Northern
Ireland and back who votes for the
people who make laws about Easter eggs
or cakes or boats or any other
manufactured goods who votes for the
people who set vat rates on sanitary uh
where in in Northern Ireland
no one in England or Scotland or Wales
and no one in Northern Ireland
and I think there was a reason as I say
the public voted Us in 80 seat majority
in 2019
and that was because they instinctively
knew
that we had to fix this
and that's why we had the bill and
look
um
get on the punch line uh I'm going to
find it very difficult to vote for
something myself because there's
something like this myself because I
believed that we should have done
something different
no matter how much plaster came off the
ceiling in Brussels
and
I hope that it will work
and I also hope that if it doesn't work
we will have the guts to
deploy that bill again
because I've no no doubt at all that
that was what brought the EU to
to negotiate seriously
and in the meantime I will continue to
campaign for for what I thought of and
what I think of as brexit and the logic
of brexit because this is nothing if it
is not a brexit government
and brexit is nothing if we in this
country don't do things differently
and we need to take advantage of it
and we need to be seen to take advantage
of it
and let me give you an example
for years the scientists have been
calling for the ability to do something
called crispr c-r-a-s-pr drugs we all
know about genome editing which for some
reason is banned under a ruling of the
ecj
well now that we're out we can
theoretically do it we can and we're
very we have we have the capabilities to
do it uh
it doesn't mean Franken Foods it doesn't
mean we're all going to be attacked by
Killer Tomatoes it will enable us to do
all sorts of things to protect crops
from uh from disease from Frost from
Blight and soft
will we do it
will the UK be in the lead
will we dare to diverge
well we're standing on the edge of the
of the diving board and it's not clear
to me that we we are going to so I say
to you let's take the plunge even if it
would appear that under this deal those
British genome
edited
tomatoes
could not go into the making of a
or whatever your cheese and tomato
sandwich in Northern Ireland
which as I say is going to be I think is
a is a matter for regret so let's dare
to be different and do things
differently and we should be dared to be
different on the economy I know that
covid cost a fortune
and there was not much we could do about
that
but we're out of it now and there's no
point now in just emulating the high tax
High spend low growth European model we
should think not about raising
corporation tax but cutting corporation
tax to Irish levels all lower and really
turbo charging investment to drive
leveling up across the whole country
really showing the world what they
wanted to see from 2016 onwards that we
are different now because this is a
brexit government or this is nothing and
it's because this is a brexit government
that we got the biggest share of the
vote since 1979. let me give you just
some examples of the ways Divergence has
helped us so far
yes it really is the case that it made a
difference that we were out of the
European medicine agency and therefore
able to get the first licensed vaccine
into the arms of any patient anywhere in
the world and that meant we had the
fastest vaccine rollout and that meant
we were able to come out of lockdown
faster than the rest of Europe and we
staged therefore the fastest economic
recovery in the G7 and we had today in
spite of all the difficulties the lowest
unemployment since about 1974 and we
will fix our problems we will fix
inflation I'm no doubt that the
government will be successful in what
they're doing in getting inflation done
and that was because
we dead that success with vaccines was
because we dared to be different and we
dared to be different on Orcas which the
I don't believe the foreign office would
ever have allowed when we were still in
the EU I don't think they would ever
have allowed such a rupture with the uh
with our French friends and the and the
the raucous caucus of the Antiochus
caucus and we dared to be different
finally
when it came to the great geopolitical
crisis that frankly dwarfs everything
that we've so far that I've so far
discussed today in which Andrew Neil
mentioned uh just before I came on
when it was clear that Putin really
might be so insane as to attack Ukraine
we were the first major European country
to send quantities of lethal Weaponry to
help them the end-law anti-tank missiles
that were so important in the battle for
Kiev and believe me
that would never have happened if we'd
stayed within the constraints of the
so-called common foreign and security
policy of the European Union
we would never have dared to be
different if we had remained as we were
deferential to the Primacy of France and
Germany on Ukraine under the so-called
Normandy process of 2014.
and all I can say is how proud I am that
by daring to be different brexit Britain
has encouraged now the rest of Europe to
give arms to the ukrainians and we know
of course that our contribution is
nothing
compared to their heroism they are
fighting for all of us they're fighting
for Georgia for Moldova for the bolts
for for Poland as Andrew rightly said
for all the periphery of the old Soviet
Empire
and yes on the on software they have the
soft power
they have a vibrant Dynamic free open
Society they have elections that can go
either way
and that is what they are defending and
that is what Putin hates and fears they
have a president
who is not only a great War leader but
who was once the voice of Paddington in
the Ukraine of Paddington the bear in in
the Ukrainian version
of the film
so I can say in the struggle between the
Russian bear and Paddington my money is
on Paddington but
sometimes soft power
needs hard power to defend it and the
ukrainians need that hard power now the
ukrainians are fighting for freedom and
democracy everywhere let us give them
what they need and give it to them now
Slava ukraini and thank you very much
for listening
[Applause]
thank you
so
um
the thought occurred to me I would ask
the audience to say who thinks brexit
was a good idea
put your hand up
okay so we don't have yeah I I got the
feeling that might be the case as we
went along
but I am undaunted as Boris changed
anyone's mind I am I am undaunted I I
won't look I mean anyway
the character the problem at the moment
and it's about what we're not getting
right now is uh any I think I said it
several times this is a brexit governor
it's nothing we got a massive uh mandate
to change people wanted a change in
their lives they wanted to see things
done differently
and you know I've got to put my hands up
for this as much as anybody uh we
haven't done enough yet to to convince
them that it can deliver the change they
want to see and I think that they're
particularly dismayed about things like
the small boats Crossing the the channel
but they all said in they don't feel the
the economic change and so we've got
we've got we've got to break out of the
the model that we're in based on what
you've just said you're obviously not
going to be supporting the The Windsor
framework does that mean that you would
expect to see um I think people have
heard quite a division like the woods i
i people they I've had people I've had
camera Crews on at my at somebody who
are asking me all week what I think
about this you've had about you've had
about half an hour uh of my of my you
nobody can say you don't know my views
on this subject now or you you might
even notice that you haven't heard might
use on this I mean
um
I what I want look it is clear that
this is where people are now and you
know it's clear from the from this room
that this is what people
people want to move on so do you think
they want to they want to do a deal they
don't want any more actions and I get
that I totally get that and I've I've
got to be realistic about it so should
there be an election
well there is going to be election we're
going to win that actually that's not
that's not until till January or you
know until the end of next year
okay fine so um just going through a few
things we're talking about Ukraine there
do you think uh there's more we could do
and is Ukraine going to win what more
can we do I think Ukraine is going to
win but it's going to be very hard and
they they need the maximum support they
need it now and my argument is why delay
you know if what happens in this
conversation we always end up giving
them stuff sooner or later what if it's
the choices between sooner or later
let's give it sooner you know we first
of all it was uh it was end-laws then it
was high Mars and it was uh then it was
tanks uh now the question is about
aviations by planes
um
it's going to happen sooner or later
let's do it sooner but do you think it's
only going to be resolved militarily or
is yes is it going to be resolved by
negotiation well look uh
classically this is people say this is
this is now uh tragically a a war in
which Ukraine the ukrainians are
fighting winning this war but they
depend on the support of us in the in
the west and they're the heroes they're
the heroes but they do need they do need
support
we must not fail in giving that support
what America has done has been
absolutely spectacular and I don't think
people have you know realized the extent
of the of the U.S support in a 45-50
billion dollars now of of support for
for Ukraine this is a massive commitment
to transatlantic security uh by The
Americans
I I do worry a bit that it could
the atmosphere in Washington could
change if Ukraine doesn't win
this year that's what needs to happen
one of the things that was coming across
in our research very strongly is that a
large chunk of the world has not got the
message I know doesn't necessarily
support the Ukraine I know we could try
that
David why don't we what do we do now I
mean we got we've got massive support
for brexit uh let's let's see
let's see I mean I thought I did pretty
well because you know how tough that
audience was I mean you've got to be
realized I had one vote in the audience
at the start of the meeting uh you know
I I I was you know the selection meeting
is good that was really very tough let's
let's just see who who's who's basically
on who's basically Ace a kind of you
crano skeptic who who is who is who who
thinks that uh
uh you know the the Russians might have
the the grain of a point who's willing
to say that in a London audience
anybody
I'm not hearing okay right that's good
that's that's solid okay what is this
it's sort of what one thing what comes
from our research is that in quite large
parts of Africa South Asia you know
North Asia they're quite sympathetic and
you know one of the problems could be
that Russia persuades China to come in
on their side give the materials because
they feel you know it's the Cold War and
they're being picked on is there a
serious jobs you think that might happen
I look I I think that's absolutely
correct I think that there are large
parts of the world uh where the it
doesn't seem as clear to to them as it
does to to you and you and me uh we feel
incentive this is right and wrong this
is good and evil uh nothing could be
clearer to me this is a sovereign
independent European country uh that was
invaded in a brutal and criminal way and
we should do everything we can to help
them protect themselves but I got to
tell you that's that's not how
um
you know whether it's because they have
governments that uh actually are quite
partial to the idea of being able to
invade their neighbors uh when they when
they choose whatever there are lots of
of
um mixed feelings about this and I think
it's certainly true that
Russian and Chinese diplomacy has been
very effective and I think I was
eavesdropping on your earlier
conversation
we need to do better in getting the
messages across and I think the BBC is
fantastically powerful and and trusted
but I I got to tell you a tragedy uh I
remember when I was in when I was
foreign secretary being told that Russia
Today
is at least as influential in some parts
of sub-Saharan Africa as the BBC and
Russia Today is actually more
influential in Latin America
than the BBC
um or more watched or I don't know about
inflation but certainly has a bigger
bigger footprint
and
that's pretty chilly I mean this was
this was years ago so so
people will only respond to the news
they consume
and
just as you're hearing a lot of bad news
about brexit
um
people people
they're they're they're listening to
that and we've got to be smarter in
communicating the reality of the
situation so I mean one of the things
that we've heard a lot about recently is
the fact that they want to boost defense
spending in the UK because of the war
and they're talking about I don't know
11 12 13 billion pounds the amount that
is actually being spent on the things
that promote communication like the BBC
and the British Council on the other
hand they're they seem to be cutting it
back and back and we had this discussion
last year and the year before where
everyone's saying they think it's crazy
that we're not actually putting far more
money into all that I mean do you have a
point of view about that well I I the
BBC gets a lot of money from the from
the license uh pair as far as I can
remember the you know I think the
gentleman in the front row was pointing
that out just now and you know that's a
that's a good thing it's a fantastic
um emanation of British soft power
I've always wondered why the BBC can't
make more money itself with all this
cash coming in
why can't they you know organizations
like Netflix they seem to make a bob or
two I think I think you know Amazon BBC
Studios you know what what about all
that uh you know we've got yeah I think
I said rather extensively in my speech
we've got the most talented uh media
world in in we've got media people in
the world here in London we've got all
sorts of cultural Advantage why aren't
we why aren't we why aren't we making
better use of our of our talent if you
look at the BBC finances they make 5
billion a year and I think about 1.6
billion of it comes from media so the
people that are sponsoring us the BBC
Studios which is the external commercial
part of BBC is making money it always
strikes me as weird that they'll cut
back the World Service which is funded
by the foreign office I think they've
just scrapped the Arab service and it's
really run on the total shoes that's
very sad I think yeah you know yeah look
I mean these these Services I tried not
to do well when I was friends I really
tried to keep all of that all of that
going and and uh although as much of the
foreign as we possibly could
um I think that is that that is sad
um but I I just I
you know restate my point
when I go to the okay when I go to BBC
Studios which I don't do as much as I
used to let me tell you for very reasons
which you will know uh
well I'm Amazed
the the contrast between those BBC
Studios and
um you know a private sector media
organization and in a BBC Studio I love
the BBC thank you BBC for sponsoring
this conference you know
et cetera uh I I owe everything to the
BBC
um they launched me
they know
um but when you go to a BBC Studio
wherever it is
um some some wonderful tunnel city of
this in this country it is absolutely
pollinating with people in polinx uh you
know doing this that or all the other
loads and loads of people with
clipboards uh you know each name what
their place in the hierarchy is
um and
you know that's not the case in
private sector media organizations where
the the cuts and the pressure uh the
shrinkage of advertising has has been so
intense that there's tumbleweed blowing
down uh the the the the the
uh uh newsrooms of some of these great
great uh local papers and many of them
have gone and many of their business
much of their business actually
cannibalized by the BBC uh because of
the of the way they give they give local
news as well so
um
it's a great big wonderful thing
but I think it was I think it was the
director General himself who was
overheard the other day saying what a
fantastic
uh there you go there's one on here uh
seeing one saying what a fantastic thing
it was uh that they were able to get so
much money from them from the license
fee and it is what I'm saying is
somebody who has to think about asking
people across the country to pay uh uh
attacks which they can be jailed for not
paying is is you know use that license
fee well and and you know use it to to
generate lots more income that's what I
think that's what I think the BBC could
do it could be the flagship for British
media around the world it could be the
great content vehicle for all the
private sector uh uh
companies all the private sector it
could be it could be the the the the
Dreadnought that sails the Seven Seas
for the for the for the for the UK and
gets our message across but I don't I
don't know if it is doing that in the
way let me just come back to brexit for
a moment yes I don't think we've had
enough about that the well come on
clearly
um I gave you about 15 paragraphs on
brexit
let me ask you this question I mean
clearly um you wanted to get it done
yeah Rishi now thinks he's got it done
when that when and if that goes through
brexit will be done so the question then
well
what really won't be but that's the
whole point
let me ask you a special point in this
that was what I that was what I decided
there's no point in this exercise if you
don't do things differently if we are
just going to stick in the in the Middle
Lane and uh be a kind of
um you know relatively High tax
relatively High spend uh very heavily
regulated uh
European economy so here's my question
yeah what would you do different I mean
I personally I find it very hard to
believe that we were going down to 19
possibly to 17 corporation tax Ireland
sat there on 12 I was I had my finger I
had my fingers I I would I would have
done in retrospect what I wish we'd done
and I spent an awful lot of time uh with
my my friend the former Chancellor now
prime minister trying to see you know
see we need you know we need to we need
to set up our store about brexit room
what I wish we had done is put a big
um invest Here sign over Britain as soon
as we were out of covid as soon as it
was remotely credible I think we should
have done something we should have
outbid the Irish we should have said
this is it
come here we will give you tax breaks of
a kind or you know so you think we
should tax rate should be ten percent
we what it needed was was
a big big sign that things were
different under the UK was the place to
come to because what's so interesting is
that I think the the global audience
when it happened
thought hmm that's interesting what are
the Brits mean by that what are they
going to do
and we had this long long long long long
long Civil War about what brexit was
and we never really and I think we
haven't yet said we're doing things
differently and that's why things like
the The genome editing
get on and do it right you know but
we've got it we've got to move what else
should we be doing well are there trade
deals we should be doing are there
relationships with other countries of
course of course but there are the
things you should be doing on financial
services on uh on on data uh there's a
there is a huge amount that we should be
getting on with and and I think that
I mean it seems to me it's someone who
did actually vote for brexit as you
probably gathered that um
agreed with the principal and wanted to
see something different there have been
several things that have been different
that you just outlined which I don't
think you get enough credit for but as
you say there is no sort of Manifesto of
things that would make a real difference
starting with tax I mean I just don't
understand why they've uh gone for high
tax rather than low tax and I don't
really know what the areas are that they
could liberalize
um maybe you should set that out
slightly stronger and then people might
support you well I I I I think that's
right but don't you know don't don't
forget it wasn't a a trivial thing that
we as I said uh just now we were able
because we
had a different regulatory regime and is
you know people will people will dispute
this but if you look it's absolutely
true we were outside the the European
vaccines uh program uh we were able to
do things very very differently and we
went we approved a vaccine faster than
any other country uh the uh medical
health health regulation agent the mhra
was able to approve I think both Pfizer
and AstraZeneca
before anybody else I'm fairly certain
of that and that gave us the
the edge in uh in rolling out that
vaccination program and that was a
totally massive thing
and you know it was a you know I would
say brexit saved lives
right and and I I I I I I I I I
absolutely would and
um at it
but people find it very difficult to
accept that point they say oh you know
they did because I I think the the the
general sort of Gloom about the subject
has been so so intense when you when you
look at stuff like the like the
chemicals regulation uh the um uh
Financial Services solvency 2 method all
those sorts of things these are areas
where we're now making progress
but I think and and Richie definitely
wants to make progress on them but we
need to be talking about it more and
I think
what we've got to avoid is the idea that
we can kind of um
make everybody love us more by
by sort of being more you know just not
being different one of the things I
would like to get your view on is that
now that we are not in the EU and we can
do what we like there are certain
countries or blocks that we might get
more friendly with I mean is for example
the Commonwealth the answer we're having
a session this afternoon yes and how
does the Queen's death impact on the
relationship with the Commonwealth the
Commonwealth is
is a brilliant institution and you know
52 countries that have many of the of
the young people the of the of the world
the future markets of the world we
should be doing a lot more with it
and I don't think as a as a country uh
we the UK realizes what an incredible
resource the Commonwealth is for us and
you know the French and the Germans used
to say to me this is fantastic we had
something like this we would make we
would make much much more of it
um so thinking specifically so I think
the it's a we need to intensify our
Commonwealth cooperation I always felt
Commonwealth Summits would just too kind
of diffuse
there were not enough clear objectives
whether on trade or or whatever it was
it was it was too General we need to
find a way of making the conversation
much much more actionable at the moment
debate about the Commonwealth is is
largely now that it's King charged not
Charles not Queen Elizabeth is that
going to result in them getting rid of
the monarchy and it gradually diluting
or do you see it as something which we
can inject more into and if so what I
think that the so the the Monarch I
don't know anybody else thinks but I
think one of the most stunning thing
about
the sad uh death of him actually the
queen
last year was how
seamless how
natural
the the transition seemed I don't know
whether it was just I was I've got to be
I was a politician as somebody who cares
passionately about it all who is what I
I I didn't know
I didn't know what would happen
and I remember being in in that in the
House of Commons when the uh the
tributes were paid to to uh her majesty
how absolutely uniform and how heartfelt
were the tributes from all benches not
just to the late Queen but also to the
new king
and how emphatic
people were in in their support
for the institution I was really really
taken even really quite hardened left
Wingers on the other benches
were very very clear about what they
thought and said and meant you could see
that they minted
I think that
the the value of the institution was
really proved so one of the things we
were talking about earlier is the
outstanding performance of the UAE yes
they are the country that has done best
seem to be making the most investment in
soft parties
yeah what can we learn from them uh have
we done things that we should be doing
better as a result yes well the UAE I
think it's a fan it's an absolutely
amazing country and
um we the UK is this like the
Commonwealth we we have total Amnesia we
forget our links and the the the flag
actually only went down in the I think
the crucial States in 1971 you know this
is this is a uh a part of the world
where like it or not the UK is deeply
familiar we should be doing far far more
and there is a massive opportunity and
um I've rather the a good fortune to
have a you know a lot of time with his
Royal Highness sir Ahmed bin Zion I've
talked to uh to him a lot about what the
the UK and the UAE could do I think what
we can learn from the UAE is
a fantastic PR
I mean it's the thing they did the thing
that was their space program yeah is
pretty good
I'm very keen on our space program which
is you know it's had a bit of a hiccup
and we need to keep going
so I think I think much more true I mean
people don't know about the extent of
UAE investment in right in the UK it's
massive but we need to we need to be I
think a lot of people don't know about
the extended investment by the UAE and
lots of things Aid in Africa space yes
all manner of different things but um
just turning to the states for a moment
I mean now that we have floating away
from Europe there were naught
that Ukraine point
I genuinely think it is true that we are
now more influential
in Europe about foreign policy
because we're outside it or outside the
EU structure than we were when we were
in it I I genuinely think it was the
site of brexit Britain doing this thing
that helped to Galvanize the rest of the
thinking about our relationship we're
not drifting away from Europe thinking
about our relationship with the us then
yes are we just the 51st state I mean
Putin says we're a poodle to do whatever
they say uh what's going to happen to
the relationship with America well I I
you know I would I obviously that's not
true because we have a we don't even
have we don't even yet have a free trade
agreement with the uh with the with the
United States
um that I think would be a good thing I
think the I think the UK and the in the
US
transatlantic relationship has been the
great fact of the last
120 years in in geopolitics it's worked
it's it's it's helped uh avert disaster
in two world wars and I think you can
see it working very well in in the worst
conflict now since the Second World War
uh as Andrew Neil rightly said that and
it's we are working hand in glove I
think it'd be you know fair to say that
um
there is strong support for the
ukrainians in both London and Washington
and the result one of the one of the
results of what has happened
Geo strategically is that NATO is very
very greatly strengthened and that that
institution in which the US has Primacy
NATO is the Incarnation of U.S military
power in in Europe uh but it also and
the UK is the number two
and
that organization is now immensely
strengthened by what is happening you
can see that but from from what Finland
and Sweden are doing but also I think
the argument's now about Ukraine so
we've got a couple of minutes left I've
just got one last question which is
really about
um you know 10 years from now what
what's your future I mean are you um I
think I I think are you going to be
running for elections
well that's an interesting idea uh no I
had to give up my I had to get I had to
give up my American citizenship because
it was becoming very very expensive
um that they're they're ruthless uh
internal tax department there
um I was born in New York so what's the
next big job is it head of NATO what is
it well I've done a lot of people out of
the Commonwealth I've I've got a big
budget of words I have to write and I
I'm I'm churning it out I'm you know
scribble scribble scribble
um I
you know I think that
um I've I'm gonna
you're returning I'm going to get on the
thing that the things I'm gonna
say uh I'm gonna I obviously need to do
a bigger a better job of explaining and
uh supporting and defending brexit and
trying to get people to understand I I
it's clear from this wonderful meeting
which I thank you uh that we need to do
more on that uh right I I care deeply
about the agenda that this government
was elected to to deliver which was
leveling up
and I do not want us to lose sight of
that the UK is hopelessly imbalanced as
an economy
it is quite quite wrong that so much
wealth and productivity should be
concentrated in in London in the south
east and a huge waste of of human and
other Capital there is a massive
opportunity for us to become the richest
country in the in Europe by a long way
if we could level up properly and I'm
going to keep going on that and the the
last thing is uh is Ukraine right and I
I kind of uh I've ever
um I was able to build a good
relationship with President zielinski
um and you're going to be doing you're
going to be doing more you know I I
think it's important to campaign for
that because I I you you the point you
made David earlier was totally right
too many people around the world don't
get it and or are apathetic
and there's also there is a risk in in
Washington
that
um
some elements of the Republican party
will start to go wobbly on it
and there's some sort of crazy stuff I
don't know you're seeing this stuff you
know people start saying that Putin is a
conservative
give me a break
um that's a disaster so so we shouldn't
expect you to be returning to the plow
in Oxfordshire anytime soon you're going
to be talking at large oh no no no no no
no no I'm I'm definitely you mean the
plight of the the pub or the
no the the Cincinnatus reference yeah no
I'm I'm going to be taking I I I I I I
think it's very very unlikely that um
you know I'll need to do any begin
policies again I've done a lot
um I think that
um you know I need to get on with with
you know trying to I got making money
well there's that right I've got big
deadlines I got big deadlines and and
pages and pages to write I think you
should take notes from uh let's see
he'll show you how to uh do the social
media is that right now we all need to
let me know anyway thank you for your
time thank you very much thank you all
for listening thank you and lunch is now
served upstairs thank you thank you very
much
thank you